hello rejects Greg here John here Billy
here
man Billy guests on the channel
snapchatter away is he also has YouTube
in a lot his YouTube Instagram all the
links are in the description box truly
modern man we're gonna check out a very
special video that does link to what we
do on this channel it's called tobey
maguire reacts to Andrew Garfield yes -
spider-man Home Coming what trailer
unsent cuz there was a video I didn't
see of Andrew Garfield reacting this
spider-man Home Coming trailer things
like when they had a spliced footage
from a movie and they don't know good
and this one is Tobey Maguire reacting
to that one like I just talked to that
one to see that so excited oh boy oh
this is a treat I'm typing it in yes
it's empty I can't
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute
you guys are the real Avengers hope
gives it away treat me like a kid all
the time but you argued this is my
chance to prove myself and everybody
haha yeah listen you were great
believe me I know the same you can't let
it bring you down you've got to believe
in yourself and you pull yourself
together you get right back home it's
genius
I actually really love the idea of manju
girlfriend Tobey Maguire having that
actual conversation yeah
cuz we could they could have that song
trust aware he's so bummed cuz he's like
he was the most recent spider-man again
tell me what girls already gone through
them yeah man it gets better
one and you also think to like Tobey
Maguire he could look back a little more
happily because people at least like the
two first fighters like Andrew Garfield
looks like you would be so bummed well
yeah receiver oh this is this cut
together really well yeah and then they
tacked on the speech from spider-man
three at the end like this is the
perfect thing good yeah it's a that's so
cool because the last two foot it the
last two pieces of footage are from
spider-man movie so like see her it is
it does make it feel like they're
talking with each other that they found
those two yeah they're part of a club
now I mean these are these guys are like
dudes who played James Bond it just
makes me yeah you played spider it feels
like spider-man is becoming like the
first like comic book version of like
what we do in James Bond in some way
yeah yeah the fact that we can keep
replacing a spider-man and be only one
besides Batman that like we've really
just been like was just
they started we started again and it's
happened so close together like that's
yeah like I wouldn't be surprised if
spider-man became our super James Bond
yes well how would your Carolyn is like
swapped about every three movies
in this weird and like a lot of other
people are okay with that yeah they're
just like masked figure but they warned
is okay with it with diamond they're
like no yeah well I'm this way and maybe
it'll make the Andrew Garfield years
better cuz people are gonna go back and
go you know I think he was my favorite
neon the same five people I think people
will really end up loving Andrew
Garfield's portrayal but they still
won't like the movies that much yeah
so anyone that season will put a hand on
our Andrew Garfield's shoulder if you
see him just say nostalgia helps no
please don't
I wonder I do it makes me really wonder
how they responded what any like
actually see these trail you know they
saw this happen yeah and your sod the
head is like damn it yeah I really
wonder like oh we will have love to
actually be in the room with them the
first time they see the trailer they
probably get into a rage fit the silence
we dish it out of houses yeah edible
you'd be like who did this we got your
shout out to them doctor Matt Mike shot
kill [ __ ] he'll knock you hey man great
job editing that together dude that was
[ __ ] really well yeah well one if you
need to the channel so subscribe to him
subscribe to the real rejects John's
Facebook medCom slash the real rejects
I'm bloom house social media manager
that nan Billy is the man of the Billy
the best Ranger the Blue Ranger billet
where's your glasses Blue Ranger
collective it like how are you child
he's up snapchat all everything else is
in the description box yeah well it's
all there Reena description box just go
there as soon as you can you don't think
you billet for coming by thanks guys
Billy's not gay
there it is ah what we click on these
three videos that Billy's Jewish and not
gay
two things I was completely wrong about
yeah